ons nos travaux et nous accueillons
donc à présent madame Marie
lordordenis dont la candidature est
proposée par le Président de la
République pour être reconduite dans ses
fonctions de président de laaknil je
vous indique que votre audition madame
auprès de la commission est retransmise
en direct sur le site internet du Sénat
je rappelle que conformément aux
dispositions de l'article 13 de notre
Constitution pendant public ne pourra ou
ne pourrait pas procéder à à votre
nomination si les votes négatifs au sein
de notre commission et de la commission
des lois de l'Assemblée nationale
représentait au moins 3/5è des suffrages
exprimés au sein des deux
commission le vote aura lieu à la suite
de votre audition qui est publique et
ouverte au public nous procéderons
immédiatement après au dépouillement en
même temps que le feront nos collègues
députés les délégations de vote je vous
le redis ne sont pas autorisées
conformément aux disposition de
l'ordonnance du 7 novembre
1958 madame la Présidente j'ai présenté
aux membres de la commission avant de
vous recevoir des éléments sur votre
action à la tête de laacnil pendant ces
5 dernières années votre premier mandat
a pris place à un moment charnière pour
la commission qui a dû répondre au défi
posé par l'entrée en vigueur en
2018 du fameux rgpd règlement général
sur la protection des données la
Commission doit désormais faire face la
vôtre en circonstance à l'entrée en
application progressive du paquet
législatif européen relatif au servicees
numérique je refuse de le prononcer en
anglais je considère que la langue de
Molière doit dominer au sein de cette
commission et trouver sa place c'est un
refus amical par rapport à nos amis
britanniques naturellement et trouver sa
place dans ce nouvel
écosystème tandis que les recours le
recours croissant aux technologies de
l'intelligence artificielle dans la vie
quotidienne vient aussi questionner les
schémas d'analyse des utilisations de
ces données vraiment c'est dire que
l'enjeu est extrêmement important vous
pourrez nous préciser brièvement bien
sûr dans un propos liminaire la manière
dont vous apprendez ces différents défis
et quel bilan vous tirez de votre
premier mandat mais avant de vous donner
la parole je souhaiterais dors et déjà
peut-être aborder quelques questions sur
l'activité et le fonctionnement de
laacnil ma première question portera sur
les perspectives générales d'évolution
de celle-ci de ces missions tout comme
toutes les les autres autorités
européennes de protection des données
laacnil exerce quatre missions
fondamentales
informer accompagner la mise en
conformité des organismes contribuer à
l'innovation et enfin contrôler et
sanctionner cependant les priorités
peuvent varier d'une autorité à l'autre
bien sûr comment envisagez-vous cet
équilibre entre ces différentes missions
au cours des 5 prochaines années pardon
et quels seront peut-être les objectifs
prioritaires de l'acnil pendant cette
période je souhaiterais dans un deuxième
temps m'attarder sur les enjeux de
coordination les sujets tra que vous
traitez dans les fonctions qui sont les
vôtres se diversifie à l'ône du
développement de nouvelles technologies
et des régulations européennes ces
missions s'élargissent voire
interagissent avec celle d'autres
autorités sur le plan national
d'ailleurs la création d'un service
dédié à l'intelligence artificielle au
sein de l'acnil bien que pertinente
pourrait peut-être même dépasser son
périmètre initial en touchant à des
enjeux industriel il en va de même de sa
nouvelle mission d'analyse économique de
la donnée comment envisagez-vous la
coordination avec les autres autorités
pour traiter ces sujets évidemment
extrêmement complexes sur le plan
européen la procédure de guichet unique
du rgpd désigne très souvent comme
autorité compétente l'autorité de
protection des données de l'Irlande pays
qui accueille la vaste majorité des
grandes plateformes numériques quel
regard portez-vous sur ceé ce mécanisme
pardon de guichet
unique comment analysez-vous la
coordination avec l'autorité irlandaise
les décisions du Comité européen de la
protection des données sont elles de
nature à faire évoluer sa propre
jurisprudence enfin à cet égard votre
prédécesseur madame FAL Pierrotin a
considérablement renforcé l'influence de
l'acnil à l'échelle européenne en
présidant le G29 depuis devenu depuis
Comité européen de la protection des
données par quel moyen pensez-vous
pouvoir consolider également cette
influence française et quelle est
l'implication actuelle de l'acnil dans
les travaux de coordination
européenne enfin en dernier lieu et j'en
terminerai par là madame la Présidente
les questions tenantes à la gestion
interne de l'institution avecun collège
composé de 18 commissaires dont nous
tenons à saluer les deux commissaires
sénateurs qui étaient là mais Monsieur
Louis kV n'est plus euh dans notre
commission des lois et également madame
Robert que je salue
euh était présent était membre
évidemment de l'acnil alors comment
l'acnil se distingue par sa taille par
rapport à d'autres autorités
administratives indépendantes qui compte
souvent moins de 10 membres comment
assurez-vous l'efficacité de la prise de
décision au sein d'un collège aussi
important est-il nécessaire d'engager
des réformes dans l'organisation et le
fonctionnement même de votre institution
dans ce contexte d'élargissement continu
de vos missions je parle des missions de
l'acnil naturellement les moyens actuels
de celles-ci vous semblent-il adaptés
comment l'acnil a-t-elle l'intention
d'assurer l'attractivité de ses postes
surtout technique d'ailleurs face à une
concurrence du secteur privé qui est
féroce sur ces sujetsl
toujours sur la question de l'adéquation
des moyens de l'institution nos
préoccupations portent sur le délai
moyen de traitement des saisines par
l'acnatteignant 7 mois en 2022 avez-vous
une stratégie ou une idée de la manière
avec laquelle vous pourriez réduire ces
délais et fluidifier le traitement des
plaintes enin je conclus en évoquant les
appels des associations de protection
des droits fondamentaux avec une plus
grande transparence dans les prises de
décisions de la commission c'est une
question de principe elle est posée
j'imagine bien que vous avez toute
capacité à pouir nous répondre là-dessus
mais votre avis nous importe enfin
comment laacnil pourrait-elle améliorer
sa communication tout en préservant son
rôle de régulateur qui soit de tenir
compte des intérêts des organismes et
entreprise accompagné voilà madame la
Présidente ce propos un peu long sans
doute mais qui vous donne capacité à
répondre à vous présenter à répondre à
l'ensemble des commissaires ici présents
sachant que nous sommes donnés 45
minutes quoi voilà ça va
aller tout à fait donc je je ne fais pas
de propos liminire si si vous dites ce
que vous avez envie de dire la parole
est libre devant cette commission
rassurez-vous il y a pas de difficulté
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur le et
et merci pour ces
question auquel pour partie et pour
partie simplement j'espère pouvoir
répondre dans ce propos liminaire et
après je note bien le temps qui qui
m'est imp parti et ah faut bien parler
dans le problème comme ça ça vous
m'entendez mieux d'accord merci merci
beaucoup comme quoi faut que la knil
apprivoise la technologie dans T dans
tous ces
aspect c'est pas
vrai monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs je
suis très honoré d'échanger avec vous
dans le cadre de cette de cette audition
pour partager le bilan de 5 années
d'action de laaknil et présenter la
façon dont j'aborderais au conditionnel
mon second mandat si l'occasion m'était
donné d'y poursuivre mon engagement à
titre liminire je voudrais remercier les
membres du collège de l'acnil et ces
agents qui au quotidien font preuve
d'une grande implication pour fournir un
service public de de qualité le bilan
que je vais présenter est aussi
naturellement le leur je souhaite avant
tout que rappeler que laacnil est une
une autorité administrative indépendante
dont le champ d'intervention couvre tous
les secteurs d'activité et c'est
probablement l'une des raisons qui
explique qu'elle a été auditionnée par
le Parlement plus de 120 fois fois
depuis 2019 dont 55 fois par le Sénat je
pense aussi utile de rappeler que mon
mandat a eu la particularité de
coïncider vous y avez fait allusion
monsieur le Président avec un certain
nombre d'événements dont trois majeurs
inédit puis la création de l'institution
le premier concerne effectivement
l'entrée en vigueur du règlement général
sur la protection des données quelques
mois après le début de de mon mandat
dans un contexte de numérisation
accélérée de la société et en pratique
cela s'est traduit par deux changements
importants une nouvelle donne juridique
euh pour les entreprises nécessitant une
action de pédagogie du régulateur et
puis une augmentation massive des
plaintes adressées à laacnil euh puisque
leur nombre a doublé depuis 2018 pour
atteindre un pic de plus de 16000 par an
16000 en 2023 le deuxième événement
c'est bien sûr la crise sanitaire liée à
la covid-19 elle a posé des questions
inédites nouvelles en matière
d'utilisation des données personnelles
et nécessiter une mobilisation sans
précédent de l'acnil pour conseiller les
pouvoirs publics accompagner la
recherche médicale et contrôler le
respect des droits des personnes sur ce
seul sujet l'ACN a rendu dans des délais
record 31 avis sur des projets de texte
répondu à 12 auditions parlementaires
transmis puis publié 5 rapports
d'évaluation pour le Parlement délivré
169 autorisations de recherche dont les
2 tiers en moins d'une semaine et
procéder à 53 contrôles enfin dans un
registre très différent le trisème fait
notable de ces 5 dernières années
concerne l'accroissement de exposition
au risques cyber principalement des
petites et moyennes entreprises des
collectivités territoriales et des
établissements hospitaliers les attaques
cyber peuvent souvent être souvent pas
nécessement mais en tout cas peuvent
être évité ou atténués en appliquant des
mesures de sécurité relativement simples
et c'est pourquoi l'acnil accentue ses
efforts d'accompagnement et de contrôle
chaque année parmi d'autres actions elle
est dite un guide de sécurité largement
accessible aux professionnels et
parallèlement le niveau de sécurisation
des données personnelles euh est évalué
lors de chaque contrôle alors ces
éléments de contexte étant rappelés je
souhaite expliquer comment ces 5
dernières années l'acnil a poursuivi
trois principaux
objectifs le premier concerne la
protection effective des données
personnelles des Français pour faire
face au nombre grandissant de cesines
l'acnil a profondément modifié son
fonctionnement je pourrais y revenir
dans le cadre de la question que vous
m'avez posé monsieur le Président
celle-ci app porté ses fruits puisque en
2022 et en 2023 nous avons pour la
première fois depuis plus de 10 ans
traité davantage de plaines que nous
n'en avons reçu la plupart d'entre elles
se résout d'ailleurs par des actions de
conciliation qui aboutissent à une mise
en conformité et seule une minorité
justifie des mesures répressives les
chiffres illustrent cette dynamique donc
chaque année 16000 plaintes analysé 300
contrôles sont déclenchés et nous avons
tripl en 5 ans le nombre de mise en
demeure et de sanctions pour totaliser
en 2023 16 68 mises en demeure et 42
sanctions dans la logique du rgpd le
montant des amendes euh prononcé s'est
élevé depuis 2019 à plus d'un demi
milliard d'euros
594 millions d'euros très exactement
avant cette date la plus grosse sanction
de l'acnil c'était de l'ordre de
quelques centaines de milliers d'euros
le second objectif de l'acnil a été
d'accompagner les administrations et les
entreprises pour leur sécurité juridique
pour leur apporter de la sécurité
juridique la protection de la vie privée
ne doit pas être vécu comme un frein à
l'innovation numérique ni avoir pour
effet de la ralentir sans raisons
objectives pour cela laacnil a renforcé
ses offres d'accompagnement et a produit
de nombreux instruments qui relèvent de
ce qu'on appelle le droit souple cela
s'est traduit pour 2019 enfin depuis
2019 par l'adoption par le collège de
laacnil de près de 500 avis sur des
projets de texte et des lois et des
règlements le plus souvent rendu publi
pour répondre au sujet sur la
transparence euh l'adoption ou la mise à
jour d'une cinquantaine d'outils de
droit souple des recommandations des
référentiels des guides le lancement
d'un cours en ligne je ne citerai pas
son acronyme en anglais monsieur le
Président suivi par plus de 170000
personnes comportant un module
d'ailleurs très prisé sur les
collectivités
territoriales nous recevons chaque année
plus de 1500 demandes de conseil
d'entreprise et de fédération
professionnelles et et nous avons un
objectif de réponse en 6 mois cette
forme d'accompagnement est utile mais
cela n'est pas suffisant et c'est
pourquoi j'ai créé deux programmes
supplémentaires pour accompagner en
continu pendant environ 6 mois certains
projets innovants d'entreprise ou
d'administration l'un est un bacassable
c'est-à-dire une sélection de projets
correspondant à un thème annuel pour
lesquels nous allons aider un organisme
pas à pas à construire sa conformité au
rgpd chaque année une dizaine organisme
en bénéficie et l'édition en cours est
consacrée aux usages de l'IA dans les
services publics par ailleurs un autre
programme non thématique a récemment été
lancé il s'agit de permettre à des
entreprises qui ont le potentiel de
devenir des acteurs majeurs de
l'innovation numérique et qui
candidatent auprès de nous d'être
conseillé par les équipes de l'acnil
pendant 6 mois sur la bonne prise en
compte des enjeux de vie privée dans
leur système d'information donc le plus
en amont possible parallèlement j'ai
voulu initier une nouvelle méthode de
régulation qui puisse produire des
effets à grande échelle sur des sujets
qui concernent le quotidien numérique
des Français nous l'avons appliqué
notamment à notre action sur les
traceurs publicitaires euh donc je ne
donne pas le nom en anglais euh pour
mais enfin pas d'indiction mais mais à
cette heure avancé en tout cas de en
plus de la matinée ça risquerait de
donner fin pour obtenir la modification
des interfaces de la majorité des grands
site pour qu'il soit aussi aisé dès le
premier écran de refuser ces traceurs
que de les accepter nous avons procéder
en 3 temps d'abord en initiant une phase
de dialogue avec les organismes et les
publics concernés pour clarifier les
règles parce que c'est le rôle essentiel
du régulateur de clarifier les règles
puis s'en est suivi une phase
d'accompagnement avant de lancer des
campagnes de vérification et de
prononcer lorsque c'était nécessaire des
mesures
correctrices nous travaillons
actuellement en appliquant cette même
méthode qui aorté ses fruit à mieux
protéger les données sensibles
exploitées par les applications de nos
téléphones portables
qui est le premier vecteur d'ailleurs
d'accès au numérique enfin le troisième
grand objectif de laacneil a été de
chercher fort naturellement à mieux
appréhender les écosystèmes qu'ell
régulent pour apporter des réponses
adaptées aux nouveaux enjeux numériques
dans ce but j'ai pris l'initiative de
créer trois services vous en avez cité
deux d'entre eux monsieur le Président
un service deintelligence artificielle
parce qu'il s'agit pour nous de
renforcer notre expertise sur ce sujet
sur ces systèmes d'évaluer les risques
pour la vie privée et de préparer
l'entrée en application du futur
règlement européen sur l'intelligence
artificielle
par ailleurs notre laboratoire
d'innovation numérique analyse les
tendances émergentes et mène des
expérimentations et enfin en effet une
mission économique est désormais chargé
d'étudier les modèles d'affaires liés à
l'utilisation des données personnelles
et de mesurer l'impact économique des
choix de
régulation ainsi durant ces C dernières
années l'acnil s'est continuellement
transformé pour répondre ou tenter de
répondre en tout cas aux attentes de ces
publics je crois pouvoir dire qu'elle
représente une boussole exigeante mais
pragmatique pour protéger la vie privée
de nos
concitoyens mais je suis aussi
consciente que dans un environnement
mouvant traversé par l'émergence de
nouvelles technologie et notamment la
révolution de l'intelligence
artificielle la seule consolidation des
actions entreprises ne serait suffire à
répondre aux enjeux aussi je dédierai le
second temps de mon intervention à
tracer les grandes lignes de mon
ambition pour un second mandat si vous
en décidez ainsi je n'aurai pas le temps
d'évoquer bien sûr tous les sujets et
pour aller à l'essentiel je me
focaliserai sur trois TR grands défis
que l'acnil devra relever à moyen terme
mon premier défi serait de concilier
développement de l'intelligence
artificielle et protection des données
personnelles j'emploie le mot défi à
dessin le rgpd c'est la minimisation des
données et l'IA demande des quantités
gigantesques de données le rgpd c'est le
tri entre données sensibles et non
sensibles et l'IA exploite toutes les
données le rgpd c'est le droit d'accéder
à ces données personnelles de les faire
modifier ou effacer comment procéder
parmi les 175 milliards de paramètres
codés par chat GPT et encore dans une
version antérieure à celle qui est
aujourd'hui en vigueur et pourtant nous
devons pouvoir nous aussi en France et
en Europe développer et maîtriser ces
nouvelles technologies ma conviction
c'est qu'il y a des réponses à ces
questions quand les moteurs de recherche
sont apparus le droit à la protection
des données personnelles a été adapté
pour essayer de trouver un équilibre
entre le bénéfice que cette innovation
apportait aux individus et la protection
des droits des personnes qui définit nos
sociétés européennes nous n'avons pas
banni les moteurs de recherche
évidemment mais l'Europe a inventé le
droit à l'oubli pour en compenser les
effets indésirables l'acnil continue de
jouer un rôle majeur dans cet équilibre
pour respecter cet équilibre et c'est un
défi du même ordre quoi que bien plus
complexe encore je pense qui se présente
à nous avec l'intelligence artificielle
j'estime que c'est le rôle de l'acnil
que devait à ne pas freiner l'éventuel
développement d'un chat GPT français
tout en protégeant ses utilisateurs pour
cela il faut indiquer aux
acteurs comment ils peuvent développer
ce type de modèle en se conformant au
rgpd et en exploitant ces marges
d'interprétation car l'intelligence
artificielle présente des risques
indubitablement et il faut donc des
garanties des précautions à prendre en
amont et des droits à garantir en aval
j'ai souhaité que l'ACN lance un plan
intelligence artificielle en mai dernier
nous avons déjà commencé à accompagner
des entreprises et des administrations
et d'ici l'été prochain nous aurons
publié un ensemble de recommandations
explicitant comment appliquer les
dispositions du rgpd en matière
d'intelligence artificielle les
premières sont déjà parues ell devraient
même être adoptées demain par le collège
de laaknil et ces travaux se poursuivent
de façon soutenue en tenant compte
naturellement du cadre réglementaire
européen le deuxième
défi rejoint les fondements originels de
l'acnil car il vise à proposer un
équilibre entre liberté et
sécurité plus que jamais cont tenu du
rôle du numérique dans notre société
laacnil doit éclairer à la place qui est
la sienne les choix des pouvoirs publics
dans l'usage des technologies à des fins
régaliennes avec pour aiguillon les mots
de Paul Valéri si l'État est fort il
nous écrase si l'État est faible nous
périssons ces propos illustre pourquoi
les avis rendus au gouvernement et au
Parlement et le contrôle des capacités
de surveillance de l'état sont une
dimension essentielle de l'activité de
l'acnil le dialogue avec les pouvoirs
publics doit permettre de garantir un
usage efficace et pertinent pour la
protection de la vie privée de ces
technologies et ainsi de renforcer la
confiance des citoyens dans les
institutions la sécurité intérieure est
un enjeu majeur de plus en plus
influencé par l'offre technologique
qu'il s'agisse des drones d'intelligence
artificielle ou du cas particulier des
caméras dites augmenté ou intelligente à
cet égard l'expérimentation en cours sur
les caméras augmentées pour les Jeux
Olympiques me semble exemplaire l'acnil
accompagne des entreprises pour vérifier
que les moyens de surveillance utilisés
dans ce contexte très particulier sont
proportionnés et que les solutions
expérimentées le seront dans le respect
du droit des personnes je remercie la
commission des Lois du Sénat d'avoir
introduit dans la loi l'accompagnement
par l'acnil des fournisseurs de caméras
augmentées afin que les conditions d'un
déploiement efficace et respectueux de
la vie privée soi dès le départ assuré
laacnil entend plus généralement
contribuer au bon déroulement des Jeux
Olympiques en accompagnant les pouvoirs
publics dans leur souci légitime
d'assurer la sécurité de cet événement
hors norme mais c'est aussi son rôle
dans le cadre d'échang déjà constructif
de veiller à ce que les enjeux de la
protection de la vie privée soient bien
pris en compte dans la déclinaison
opérationnelle je pense notamment à la
collecte des données personnelles pour
l'accès à des périmètres sécurisés le le
troisème défi que l'acnil doit selon moi
se donner est tout à fait essentiel car
il touche à la protection des enfants et
des adolescents dans leurs interactions
avec le numérique ce sujet est sans
doute le plus urgent et le plus complexe
la délégation au droits des femmes et la
commission d'enquête sur l'utilisation
du réseau social TikTok se sont saisis
de cet enjeu et le Sénat en a aussi
débattu lors de l'examen du projet de
loi visant à sécuriser et réguler
l'espace numérique les effets
indésirables du numérique sur les
enfants et les adolescents justifient
une très grande vigilance celle-ci passe
par un accompagnement volontariste des
mineurs et de leurs parents dans leurs
usages numériques et par une protection
efficace de leurs données en pratique
pour renforcer la protection des enfants
en ligne laacnil doit d'abord continuer
à produire des contenus pédagogiques
comme elle l'a fait récemment pour les 8
100 ans et élargir les publics visés
ensuite accompagner les organismes pour
qu'ils prennent en compte les
spécificités du jeune public notamment
en déployant des mentions d'information
adapté à l'exercice de leur droit si
besoin en utilisant des iconnes ou des
vidéos je pense tout particulièrement au
droit à l'effacement de leord donné qui
mérite toute notre attention enfin
l'acnil doit renforcer ses contrôles en
particulier sur le respect de
l'obligation d'exiger un contrôle
parental pour l'inscription des mineurs
de moins de 15 ans sur les réseaux
sociaux en conclusion et en étant
consciente de ne pas avoir eu le temps
d'évoquer de nombreux sujets je veux
souligner que l'acnil veille à ce que le
numérique soit bien au service de chaque
citoyen comme le prévoit l'article 1er
de la loi Informatique et Liberté cette
position se reflète dans la promotion du
rgpd comme vecteur de confiance le
respect de la vie privée qu'il porte
conditionne le développement de
l'innovation numérique dans un cadre
respectueux des droits et des libertés
fondamentaux
ensuite cette volonté d'accompagner nos
concitoyens dans leur quotidien
numérique doit se traduire par une plus
grande capacité de projection de l'acnil
sur l'ensemble du territoire y compris
outremè les les cinq manifestations
d'ampleur que nous avons organisé en
2023 à Lyon à Marseille à Reims à Rennes
à Toulouse ont confirmé que les
professionnels les élus les particuliers
tirent parti d'un contact direct sur le
terrain avec l'acnil qui elle-même
s'enrichit de ces interactions l'acnil
peut d'ailleurs compter sur le soutien
des trois grandes associations d'élus
que sont l'association des mères de
France département de France et région
de France avec lesquelles j'ai noué des
partenariats c'est donc en combinant
pédagogie proximité et contrôle que
l'acnil pourra activement euh contribuer
à ce que chaque individu bénéficie d'une
innovation respectueuse de ses droits
voici la belle ambition qui m'anime
partagé par les membres du collège et
les agents de la Commission Nationale
Informatique et Liberté je vous remercie
de votre attention en espérant ne pas
avoir été trop longue pour pouvoir
répondre à vos questions parfait madame
la Présidente c'était parfait merci
alors il y a des demandes de parole la
Monsieur Jérôme Durin qui prendra la
parole en premier et ensuite madame
Marie
Mercier madame la Présidente merci pour
la clarté de votre propos et le souci
d'équilibre dont vous témoignez dans
dans les ambitions que vous avez pour
votre
institution j'ai pleine confiance dans
l'acnil pour réguler les usages
autorisés ou non autorisés qui lui sont
soumis on sait que les capacités
budgétaires de cette autorité
administrative indéente ont augmenté ces
dernières années on sait que la tâche
est importante et que vos ressources ne
sont malgré tout pas
infinies certaines entités publiques ou
privées déclarent pas systématiquement
les US US AG qui sont à la frontière de
ce qui est autorisé en 2023 on a par
exemple appris l'utilisation supposée
par des Service de police de technologie
de reconnaissance faciale l'acnil a
diligenté une procédure de contrôle à ce
sujet ça m'inspire de questions d'abord
quelle conclusion tire l'acnil de cette
procédure de de contrôle et puis
deuxièmement quels sont les moyens
supplémentaires qui vous permettrai qui
permettra l'acnil de parvenir à à des
Capac capité de contrôle plus large pour
des entités publiques ou privé qui
seraient un peu oublieus de leurs
obligations
merciique madame la Présidente que
Monsieur Durin ainsi que Monsieur
debress et Monsieur de Bet ont commis un
rapport sur ce point particulier il y a
maintenant un peu plus de quelques mois
je vais dire pour pas dire quelques
années mais quelques
mois
madame merciervez la
parole merci monsieur le Président à mon
tour de de vous féliciter madame pour
votre volonté de faire aboutir les
choses et votre
professionnalisme sans surprise je vais
revenir sur la loi de juillet 2020 qui
est non appliqué encore à ce jour
puisque les sites qui sont très habiles
usent de tous les moyens je rappel pour
nos collègues c'est la protection des
enfants sur les films pornographiques
gratuits or cette loi se trouve
télescopée par la loi serine je prendrai
un seul
argument la la député madame Périne
Goulet en octobre 2023 a fait adopter un
amendement contre l'AVE du gouvernement
pour protéger les enfants des jeux
numériques en calquant le dispositif sur
celui proné par le ministre barraau dans
la loi serereine c'est-à-dire contrôler
l'âge par un référentiel si ça ne
fonctionne pas on va au tribunal sans
juge elle a fait adopter cet amendement
pour protéger les enfants le ministre
barreau a émis un avis négatif en disant
que tout le monde savait que ce
dispositif ne tiendrait pas en droit et
qu'il serait
inopérant c'est-à-dire que on considère
que ça ne fonctionnera pas on le sait
donc on va certainement pas le faire
adop le noter pour les jeux numériques
mais queon le met quand même pour
protéger les enfants entre guillemets
protégés de la vie vision de site
pornographique gratuit puisque de toute
façon comme il l' expliqué avec des mots
très clairs ça ne fonctionnera pas donc
j'aimerais madame avoir votre avis sur
ce dispositif ce référentiel qui est
quand même censé protéger les enfants de
contenu qui ne sont pas adaptés à leur
âge merci madame de la
ganterie merci monsieur le Président
merci madame la Présidente de votre de
votre intervention et surtout de vos
travaux efftivement nous sommes très
fiers en je sais pas si le terme est
adapté mais de la la grande qualité de
de l'investissement de nos collègues
Sylvie Robert et lev dans ses travaux et
et des travaux de l'acnil de manière
générale Jérôme Durin il a fait
référence et je voulais prolonger son sa
question concernant la procédure de
contrôle que vous avez immédiatement
lancé en direction du ministère de
l'intérieur ce qui est d'ailleurs une de
vos de des qualités clacnil c'est que
lorsqu'il y a un sujet qui apparaît vous
avez une réelle
réactivité lorsqu a été révélé
l'utilisation par un grand nombre de
services de police de d'un logiciel de
vidéosurveillance briefcam qui avait une
fonction de reconnaissance faciale donc
Jérôme Durin vous vous interrogez pour
savoir quel était le résultat de ce
contrôle si tantit qu'il soit terminé
parce que je ne sais pas mais je voulais
préciser et vous demander quel était le
chant temporel de ce contrôle pourquoi
euh dans le cadre de nos auditions sur
la mise en œuvre des règles enfin de la
législation sur la sécurité dans les
Jeux Olympiques un haut-fonctionnaire de
la police
nationale interrogé sur ce
point nous a fait une révélation une
réponse assez étonnante et nous a dit
euh on nous a demandé de ne plus nous en
servir parce qu'il y avait une enquête
euh expliquant ensuite que
l'expérimentation avait beaucoup de
vertuus et que il y avait bien dû y
avoir une déclaration à laacnil bref
donc je je ne doute pas de votre
sagacité mais je je voilà je voulais
juste m'assurer que votre contrôle
n'était pas juste au moment où le
contrôle s'exerce mais également pour
l'activité passée puisqu'il semble
qu'effectivement ce ha fonctionnaire est
reconnu que ce logiciel était utilisé
dans le cadre de la reconnaissance
faciale merci Madame
madameeld merci monsieur le Président je
m'associe aux propos de mes collègues
pour vous remercier de à la fois des
travaux effectués jusque-là dans le
casadre de votre mandat et et vous
remercier aussi de la clarté de vos vos
propos liminires euh ma question porte
euh sur les collectivités locales vous
en avez parlé à à plusieurs reprises
puisqu'elles sont évidemment concerné
elle aussi par par ces questions pas
seulement les entreprises et j'aurais
aimé savoir quel est le regard que vous
porter sur la manière dont les
collectivités locales appréhendent
aujourd'hui à travers la question des
données personnelles et notamment du
rgpd la cyber
malveillance puisque vous avez
évidemment évoqué votre collaboration
avec lany aujourd'hui les collectivités
sont comme d'autres victimes de cyber
malveillance et évidemment quand elles
le sont ce qui leur est souvent volé ce
sont des données qui peuvent être mal
protégé d'un point de vue informatique
et là on est sur le point cyber mais qui
peuvent aussi être mal protégés parfois
du point de vue knil ou rgpd donc je aur
aimé avoir votre regard au regard de vos
5 années d'expérience sur cette question
et peut-être savoir aussi quelles sont
vos propositions pour l'avenir en la
matière
merci merci Monsieur Bourgi c'est la le
dernier intervenant inscrit merci
Monsieur aura pas d'autre parfait merci
monsieur le président madame la
Présidente merci beaucoup pour votre
exposé pour pour le travail accompli par
vous et vos équipes je voudrais partir
de deux situations très concrète pour
naturellement pas les évoquer mais pour
vous interroger sur la doctrine et les
délais de réponse de laacnil et j'ai eu
l'occasion de vous saisir à deux
occasions euh à deux reprises pardon la
première pour un détournement de
fichiers associatif dans le cadre d'une
campagne électorale vous m'avez répondu
dans des délais qui étaient assez brefs
assez diligeents et je vous en remercie
et la seconde fois où j'ai eu l'occasion
de vous euh saisir ça concernait une
suspicion d'établissement de fichiers
dans une académie d'élèves en raison euh
de leur euh de leur religion et euh j'ai
reçu un accusé de réception et à ce jour
je n'ai pas reçu de réponse sur le fond
depuis plusieurs mois donc j'écarte la
situation concrète pour poser la
question de la doctrine euh est-ce qu'il
y a une réponse systématique sur le fond
qui est euh faite au sollicitation que
vous recevez et est-ce qu'il y a euh une
distorsion entre les moyens nécessaires
aux traitements que
vous au réclamations que vous recevez
qui sont de plus en plus nombreuses et
qui justifieraient éventuellement un
décalage dans le temps sur les réponses
sur le fond les accusés de réception
tout le monde les reçoit les réponses
sur le fond on a constater un retard
dans le traitement des
réclamations merci je vais vous donner
la parole en rappelant à l'ensemble des
collègues que l'audition d'aujourd'hui
est une audition euh pour conforter ou
pas euh la candidature de madame la
Présidente que si euh euh elle est
confortée dans sa présidence on la fera
revenir pour discuter des questions de
fond n'est-ce pas et sur la base du
rapport annuel de laaknil ça fera fera
une occasion mais bon madame la
Présidente vous pouvez pouvez répondre
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président et
je suis très sensible à toutes les
questions qui ont été posées qui
traduisent et et je sais le vif intérêt
que que vous posez enfin en tout cas que
vous prêtez aux problématiques qui sont
traitées par l'acnil au jour le jour
alors monsieur le Président je vais
commencer bien naturellement par vos
questions sur les perspectives générales
d'évolution de nos mission vous en avez
cité quatre informer
accompagner l'innovation
et contrôler euh je aujourd'hui on fait
beaucoup d'accompagnements comme je l'ai
un peu montré dans mon propos liminire
on traite toutes les plaintes on on
essaie de prendre des mesures qui ont
une certaine valeur
d'exemplarité et qui servent à diffuser
des B bonnes pratiques en tout cas tel
est leur vocation euh c'est vrai qu'il
faut peut-être qu'on fasse davantage
encore sur l'information mais
l'information on met beaucoup de contenu
sur notre site qui est euh consulté près
de 12 millions de fois par an euh
c'était 8 millions il y a il y a 5 ans
donc je pense qu'il y a quand même un
certain nombre de contenus qui sont
utiles pour des professionnels et des
particuliers euh on fait beaucoup de
pédagogie aussi à l'égard des mineurs et
de leurs parents parce que ça marche
vraiment dans les deux sens beaucoup de
d'action d'éducation numérique mais je
pense que sur l'information il faut
encore essayer de nous nous renforcer et
et c'est une des raisons je l'aiévooqué
en conclusion de mon propos liminaire
pour lesqueles alors que nous n'avons
pas de service déconcentrés nous
essayons de plus en plus de nous
projeter sur le terrain d'abord parce
qu'on apprend des choses et et ensuite
parce que c'est là qu'il y a des
problématiques concrètes et qu'on peut
toucher des publics auquels on n'a pas
accès autrement et ça je veux vraiment
amplifier cette action
euh vous avez ensuite posé une question
sur
euh le service de l'intelligence
artificielle avec une problématique qui
était est-ce que ça tangente pas des
intérêts industrielle toute la
philosophie justement de l'action du
collège de l'acnil et de ses services
sur l'intelligence artificielle c'est
vraiment d'arriver à combiner cette
innovation qui présente des bénéfices
des gains de productivité qui va
permettre une médecine plus
personnalisée plus préventive et
naturellement parce que c'est le rôle de
l'acnil d'essayer de parer les risques
qui sont importants aussi avec des
traitements qui peuvent comporter des
biais des erreurs qui peuvent être alors
qu'il ne devrait pas l'être complètement
automatisé et cetera euh donc c'est bien
la raison pour la la la laquelle nous
essayons de façon très concrète là dans
les fiches que nous avons enfin que nous
publierons que nous avions mis en
consultation publique par exemple sur la
sur la finalité parce que tout
traitement de données doit avoir une
finalité logiquement on collecte pas des
données comme ça pour voir ce qu'on en
fera dans dans 3 ans et ben on dit et
ben il faut quand même nous dire deux
chose c'est quel type de système vous
utilisez alors par exemple un système de
vision par ordinateur et pourquoi bah
pour détecter des objets des voitures
des panneaux de signalisation des
piétons ça ça donne voilà c'est pas ça
empêche pas l'innovation ça empêche pas
l'industrie de fonctionner sur la
minimisation des données c'est pareil
quand on interagit avec un laboratoire
pharmaceutique qui vous dit moi je
cherche
à voilà à à à trouver les variables qui
expliquent le cancer de la prostate et
on va prendre des centaines de millions
de dossiers de patients qui n'ont pas de
cancer de la prostate ça peut se
comprendre peut-être pas dans cette
proportion là mais parce qu'il faut bien
classifier ceux qui en ont ceux qui en
ont pas pour en en déduire un certain
nombre d'enseignement mais quand on voit
qu'il y a des données de de femmes dans
les dans les patients en question on
peut se poser des questions sur la
pertinence des des données voilà quel
est un des rôles de l'acnil en matière
d'intelligence artificielle minimisation
des données finalités et je pourrais
continuer comme ça je vais je vais pas
le faire bien entendu mais tout ça pour
vous dire que notre volonté et
d'ailleurs on le montre dans nos actions
d'accompagnement les actions
d'accompagnement renforcé dont j'ai
parlé nous accompagnons hugging face qui
comme son nom l'indique pas est une
société créée par des français et en
partie établ en France qui fait de l'a
Open Source
euh pour que les les enjeux soit de
protection de vie privée soit intégré en
amont donc entre accompagnement et
production d'une doctrine pour décliner
des principes du rgpd qui sont
relativement généraux et souples on
espère mais après il faudra
naturellement se coordonner avec nos
homologues européens tout ça dans le
cadre du
ria pouvoir articuler des des ambitions
différentes en ce qui concerne la
mission économique moi j'étais ça m'a
paru être nécessaire l'acnil en fait a
une régulation qui a un impact
économique on l'a vu
sur les actions qu'on a entreprises en
matière de profilage publicitaire
l'action qu'on a faite sur les traceurs
publicitaires ça naturellement une
influence sur l'écosystème de la
publicité et nous devons comprendre à
forceori dans un contexte où il y a
quelques très très grands acteurs du
numérique dont le modèle d'affaires
repose sur les données nous devons
comprendre ces modèles d'affaires de
même que quand on fait une régulation o
où qu'on va devoir s'intéresser de très
près et on a commencé à au aux voitures
autonomes et aux données personnelles
qu'elles aspirent euh savoir des données
quand même très sensibles la
géolocalisation avec qui sont partagé
ces données tout ça dans une chaîne de
valeur que que vaut la donnée de
géolocalisation il faut avoir les moyens
de nos ambitions pour réguler au plus
près et et de façon juste et je prendrai
un exemple récent nous avons fait un
colloc il y a quelques semaines avec
l'Autorité de la concurrence où il y
avait 300 personnes en salle et 1000
personnes en ligne euh qui est intitulé
une ambition commune parce que nous
avons un certain nombre de
problématiques communes où je saisi
l'Autorité de la concurrence et
l'Autorité de la concurrence nous saisit
pour traiter un certain nombre de
cas que ce soit précisément sur des
sujets publicitaires ou autrees et sur
les applications mobiles qui est une
régulation qu'on veut faire parce que
comme on l'a fait sur les traceurs
publicitaires parce qu'il y a des enjeux
protection des données très important
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de données
sensibles dans vos téléphones portables
et dans vos applications beaucoup plus
que quand vous naviguez sur Internet en
réalité vos données de contact les
coordonnées les photos les vidéos et
cetera
euh il faut là aussi arriver à à décoder
un peu tout cet écosystème et j'ai
demandé à l'Autorité de la concurrence
un avis sur les préconisations qu'on va
faire pour réguler le secteur des
applications mobiles parce que nous
sommes conscients qu'il y a des enjeux
économiques il y a des enjeux
concurrentiels et que il faut essayer
d'articuler toutes ces problématiques
vous m'avez ensuite monsieur le
Président interrogé sur l'Europe puisque
laacnil est probablement une des
autorités administratives indépendante
qui a la régulation la plus intégrée au
sein de ce comité européen des données
qui a certes succédé au G29 mais avec
des compétences beaucoup plus grande pas
tant sur le plan de la production de la
doctrine même si le CEPD comme on dit
donc cet ensemble des européenne a
produit depuis 5 ans plus de
60 le recommand tion ligne directrices
et cetera que parce que et ça c'est
nouveau il y a un traitement
transfrontalier et en coopération des
plaintes et des dossiers avec comme vous
l'avez souligné des autorités qui ont je
me permet de le dire en anglais le le
lead
euh donc très concrètement laacnil
irlandaise effectivement parce que
c'était un des aspects de de votre
question et compétente pour prononcer
des sanctions contre la cas totalité des
gfames à l'exception d'amazone qui est
implanté au
Luxembourg et de quelques autres qui
sont pas des gfames uber est au Pays-Bas
et cetera
et certes euh
pendant il a fallu un peu de temps à ce
comité européen et c'est bien normal
pour apprendre à travailler ensemble
pour traiter toutes les plaintes et je
crois qu'il y a eu plus de
60000 dossiers et plaines qui ont été
traité pour quand même un montant en
terme d'amende qui dépasse 4 milliards
d'euros d'AM prononcé par l'ensemble des
kiles européennes depuis 5 ans donc on
peut pas dire que ça fonctionne pas ça
ça fonctionne et surtout avec des
capacités d'injonction comme nous en
France qui permettent de faire modifier
concrètement des pratiques parce qu'on
pourrait se dire les gens du numérique
ils peuvent acheter en quelque sorte
leur nonconformité en attendant 2 3 ans
une sanction et puis quit à la payer ça
leur fait gagner du temps et et ils
prennent de l'avance sur un certain
nombre de sujets il y a quand même eu
une amende prononcée par acneil
irlandaise d'un milillard 200 million
d'euros contre ma mais pourquoi du fait
de l'action des autres kniles et
notamment de la knil française qui est
très impliqué sur tous ces sujets qui
non seulement transmet des plaintes mais
n'a pas hésité au bout d'un certain
temps en ne voyant pas un certain nombre
de sanctions émerger du côté de laacide
irlandaise qui av peut-être ses propres
préoccupations ses propres contraintes
et
cetera pour utiliser les mécanismes
contraignants qui permettent d'imposer à
une des autorités de protection des
données européennes de prendre des
sanctions à la majorité des 2 tiers puis
à la majorité s'il y a deux tours et
cetera pour prendre des amendes donc
voilà je je crois vraiment que en tout
cas pour
euh rencontrer à leur demande
relativement régulièrement un certain
nombre de représentants desg FEM
lorsqu'ils viennent à Paris
euh je pense qu'ils ont compris qu'il y
avait une régulation européenne et que
la cil française jouait un rôle
important dans ce
sens vous m'avez ensuite interpellé
monsieur le Président sur le le collège
18 membres donc quatre sénateurs enfin
deux sénateurs et deux députés quatre
parlementaires excusez-moi et et je ne
peux que rejoindre ce qui a été dit sur
la qualité euh de la présence et des
interventions euh de Sylvie Robert et de
loï kvé euh bien entendu alors
effectivement c'est un collège euh
beaucoup plus grand enfin dans sa
quantitativement que les autres Aï il
faut préciser euh et et vous le savez
que ce sont des membres qui ne sont pas
à temps plein euh contrairement à
d'autres ai aussi hein qui ont 5in ou
SEP membres du collège mais qui sont
sont à temps plein donc ceci peut aussi
expliquer cela en ce qui concerne la
taille ça permet d'avoir une grande
diversité de points de vue et contenu de
la variété d'émissions de l'acnil qui
touche autant l'éthique des enjeux
juridiques économiques
technologiques c'est important d'avoir
cette richesse au sein du du collège je
n'ai pas le sentiment que ça impacte
l'efficacité des prises de
décision mais il faut bien dire que
l'essentiel de l'activité du collège est
et
et euh accaparé par les avis qu'elle
rend sur les projets de loi et les
projets de décret alors qu'il y a bien
d'autres sujets qui méritent aussi
d'être traités qui ne sont donc pas tous
traités au niveau du collège et quant à
une éventuelle réforme de la composition
du collège je crois qu'elle ne pourrait
que euh enfin avoir du sens que dans le
cadre d'éventuelles compétences qui
seraiit confié à laacnil en matière
d'intelligence artificielle au-delà de
celle naturelle que j'ai déjà évoqué euh
et qui mériterait qu'on s'attache dans
ces cas-là des compétences plus
particulières me semble-t-il mais c'est
pas à moi d'en décider en tout état de
cause mais au législateur en ce qui
concerne les moyens euh nous avons fait
beaucoup de d'efforts en tout cas pour
rendre les parcours professionnels à
l'acnil plus attractifs parce que
maintenant naturellement il y a une
concurrence et vous l'avez souligné
notamment sur les métiers
d'informaticien d'ingénieur et et même
de juriste parce que maintenant il y a
un secteur de déléguer la protection des
données de responsables des données dans
les entreprises dans les administrations
et cetera donc on a eu on a un groupe de
travail sur les parcours professionnels
on essaie de pouvoir concrètement autant
que possible mieux rémunérer aussi nos
agents qui sont très impliqués
euh et donc les je dois dire que les
pouvoirs publics ont globalement soutenu
l'action de l'acnil en ce qui concerne
l'augmentation des effectifs qui lui
paraissaient nécessair et les
moyens budgétaires même si nous sommes
beaucoup plus petits et peut-être du
coup peut-être plus productif que
d'autres homologues qui ont trois fois
plus d'agents pour des prérogatives pour
des prérogatives similaires le délai
moyen des traitement de l'acnil ça me
permettra de rebondir peut-être sur la
dernière question qui a été posée aussi
et vous avez évoqué monsieur le
Président euh il faut bien voir et je me
permets de le dire non pas pour moi mais
parce que c'est le travail des agents et
et de la réorganisation qui qui a été
faite c'est arriver à traiter euh 16000
plaintes au lieu de 8000 euh ça supposa
des efforts de réorganisation intense
euh je je rentre pas dans les détails on
a fait deux services avant il y en avait
qu'un on a fait l'externalisation de de
réponse à des plaintes les plus en qui
posaient le moins de problème
c'est-à-dire des demandes
d'accès voilà on a maintenant grâce au
législateur aussi une procédure de
sanction simplifiée qui nous permet
d'aller plus vite pour
[Musique]
euh indiquer aux responsables de
traitement de données quels sont les
manquement qui pose problème et leur
esquisser des pistes de solution euh et
alors pour répondre du coup sur cette
partie làà de la
question qui m'a été posée par Monsieur
Husen Burget Burget Burget merci
euh alors d'abord je me réjouis que vous
ayez eu déjà une réponse rapide à la
première de vos cisines et et quant à la
deuxème je je vois très bien à quoi vous
faites allusion et je pense que le délai
de traitement de ce dossier est moins dû
au moyen de l'acnil euh qu'aux
interactions que nous avons avec le
responsable de traitement qui sont un
peu longs un peu trop longs
à voilà mais vous vous en entendrez
certainement parler vous aurez une
réponse ça je peux m'y engager
[Musique]
euh améliorer la communication oui c'est
un enjeu essentiel c'est un enjeu
essentiel par par exemple quand nous
faisons les bacs àables nous faisons
systématiquement une restitution sur
Internet euh des bonnes pratiques qui
ont été dégagées pour que ça ne
bénéficie pas à quat ou 5 ou 10
entreprises mais à l'ensemble
euh des entreprises ou des
administrations sur les usages de l'IA
euh d'un secteur euh on reçoit 600
sollicitations médiatiques par an euh
donc je crois qu'il y a un vrai appétit
ou intérêt en tout cas euh des des
médias et des personnes sur ces sujets
on cherche pas à faire de buzz on
cherche à être efficace et à euh remplir
notre mission aussi bien que
possible alors Monsieur Durin et Madame
de La Gonterie ont posé euh des
questions euh sur l'éventuel ou possible
utilisation de reconnaissance faciale
notamment par le ministère de
l'Intérieur et ou des collectivités
locales euh donc effectivement ce sont
des informations qui sont parues dans la
presse le 14 novembre le 15 novembre
j'ai diligenté euh une enquête
euh euh sur la temporalité nous avons
déjà commencé à enfin nous avons adressé
un un questionnaire extrêmement fourni
au ministère de l'Intérieur et et nous
espérons avoir qui qui lui-même a
diligenté une enquête interne qui a été
confiée à l'inspection générale de
l'administration donc nous espérons
avoir des réponses d'ici la fin du mois
de février à ces à ces questions euh à
partir de quoi nous verrons dans quelle
mesure euh nous diligentons des
contrôles sur place pour pouvoir enfin
les cibler ou les identifier au mieux
sachant que parallèlement en ce qui
concerne les collectivités locales ces
questions de vidéo algorithmique ont
fait l'objet d'une thématique
prioritaire de contrôle en 2023 et nous
avons contrôlé nous sommes en train de
contrôler cette collectivités locales
euh il faut bien voir par rapport au
logiciel que dont vous avez pas cité le
nom mais qui appartient à une société
israélienne qui elle-même été rachetée
je crois par une japonaise que ça n'est
pas parce qu'on utilise ce logiciel que
nécessairement on utilise de la
reconnaissance faciale puisque il y a
des
fonctionnalités voilà parce qu'il y a
des fonctionnalités dites c'est pas
c'est pas mes propos mais les propos du
fournisseur avancé comme ça peut être le
lapis le suivi des personnes ou
précisément la reconnaissance faciale
pour lesqueles il faut acheter la
licence et une fois qu'on a acheté la
licence il faut avoir activé la
fonctionnalité et j'ai posé madame la
sénatrice exactement la même question au
service des contrôles de l'acnil parce
que sinon c'est un peu chercher une
aiguille dans une botte de foin en leur
disant mais concrètement si on va
contrôler est-ce qu'on verra si ça a été
activé alors que ça ne le serait plus et
on m'a dit que oui alors sauf peut-être
dans une hypothèse que je ne préfère pas
donc préfère pas parler dans une
audition publique et dont on m'a dit que
de toute façon on pourrait s'en rendre
compte donc moi je suis pas technicienne
mais on m'a dit que compenu de la
configuration et cetera on devrait
pouvoir faire des contrôles tout à fait
efficace madame la sénatrice Mercier
naturellement m'a interrogé et c'est
bien
normal en tant que vice-présidente de la
délégation des droits des enfants
parallèlement sur les contrôle de l'âge
pour l'accès au sites pornographique
c'est vraiment un enjeu très important
madame Mercier connaît mieux les
chiffres que moi mais il y a des
millions d'enfants qui sans avoir du
tout ont comme première expérience si
j'ose dire de la de de la sexualité
cette approche là ce qui n'est pas sans
conséquence
euh donc à un moment et j'ai eu
l'occasion d'avoir des discussions avec
Madame merciier et à l'occasion d'un
petit déjeuner qui qui que vous aviez
très gentiment organisé où il y avait
une trentaine de sénateurs est apparu le
fait qu'il pourrait y avoir des tensions
entre protection de la vie privée et la
volonté de mieux protéger les enfants et
sur le papier il y en a parce que sur le
papier aucun pays au monde n'a créé un
fichier
euh avec des cartes d'identité des
personnes qui consulte des sites
pornographiques pour prouver qu'ils ont
plus de 18 ans mais la volonté de
l'acnil et j'espère vraiment avoir par
l'action qui a été mené réussi à
convaincre tout le monde a vraiment été
de dire en tout état de cause il faut
qu'on se retrouve les manches pour
trouver des solutions et alors même que
ça n'est pas dans l'ADN de l'acnil
l'acnil a tout de suite dit avec son
collège on peut dès maintenant et après
je vais venir sur le fond de votre
question qui est-ce que ce référentiel
est-ce que ça marche et cetera euh dit
qu'on pouvait utiliser deux qui avait
deux façons qui n'étaient pas enfin deux
moyens qui n'étaient pas parfaits loin
de là mais qu'on pouvait mettre en œuvre
tout de suite c'était l'utilis pour
freiner l'arrivée des plus jeunes en
tout cas sur les sites pornographiques
c'était la carte bancaire à 0 € ou à 1 €
enfin 100 transaction tout ça avec un
tiers de confiance parce qu'en plus il y
a des enjeux cyber aussi hein sur tous
ces ces sujets là après d'amsonnage
ou d'usurpation d'identité si on donnait
des des des cartes d'identité et cetera
donc utilisation de la Carte Bancaire
alors quand on a 16 17 ans on peut
peut-être accéder à une carte bancaire
quand on en a 12 ou 13 c'est quand même
plus compliqué et par ailleurs alors là
alors que là aussi c'est pas vraiment
dans l'ADN de l'acnil on a dit bah tous
les dispositifs qui existent aujourd'hui
d'estimation de l'âge par reconnaissance
du visage mais ça n'est pas de la
reconnaissance faciale il s'agit pas
d'identifier les gens mais il y a des
systèmes il y a notamment une société
anglaise qui qui fait ça et il y en a
certainement d'autres permettent quand
même euh en tout cas font la part des
choses entre un enfant qui a 14 ans et
et un jeune adulte qui a 19 ans
maintenant entre 17 et 19 ans peut-être
moins mais et donc ces deux systèmes là
laacnil alors que laacn la limite si
elle avait campé sur ses positions
aurait pu dire protection de la vie
privée c'est très dangereux et cetera a
dit vous pouvez tout de suite mettre ça
en place d'ailleurs la secrétaire d'État
à l'enfance a repris cette même idée
maintenant sur le référentiel que vous
citez qui logiquement doit être soumis
pour avis à l'acnil dans le cadre de la
loi sine enfin dont la commission mix
paritaire je crois est prévu en février
je crois que l'arcom avec laquelle nous
avons engagé vraiment beaucoup de
travaux il y a eu beaucoup d'interaction
entre les services de laacneil et les
services de l'arcom je crois que l'arcom
qui réunit son collège ce matin est en
train d'adopter ce référentiel nous
avons déjà fait passer à l'arcom un
certain nombre de messages sur son
projet ce projet va ensuite être soumis
d'après ce que j'ai compris par l'arcom
va être mis en consultation publique et
après il sera adressé à l'aknil pour que
son collège rendre un avis officiel
dessus comme vous le savez largement
aussi bien que moi si ce n'est mieux le
gouvernement a lancé une expérimentation
depuis le mois de mars dernier sur le
sujet il y a un certain nombre d'acteurs
qui viennent nous voir qui disent qu'ils
y participent
on avec notre prisme on les accompagne
autant qu'on peut mais c'est quand même
l'arcom qui est responsable en charge de
ce dossier plus que nous même si
naturellement nous interagissons très
bien ensemble madame la Présidente je
vais vous amener à arriver à votre
conclusion tout à fait euh car nous
allons devoir voter tout à fait alorsoui
alors je voudrais surtout pas vous
empêcher de voter mais donc sur les
collectivités locales mais mais
peut-être
peut-être je ne sais pas en tout cas sur
les collectivités local euh nous sommes
très actifs très conscients qu'il y a
des enjeux de données importants nous
faisons beaucoup d'accompagnement le
module du cours en ligne de l'acnil sur
les collectivité locale a été vu 40000
fois nous avons un Service des délégués
à la protection des données qui s'occupe
plus particulièrement des collectivités
locales voilà nous sommes très actifs et
peut-être pourrons-nous poursuivre cette
discussion collectivités sont actives
est-ce que les collectivités sont
actives en tout cas elles ont elles ont
toutes les régions tous les départements
toutes les communautés de communes et
cetera ont nommés des délégués à la
protection des données et il a fallu que
je fasse une vingtaine de mises en
demeure publique pour des communes de
plus de 2500 habitants de de 20000
habitants excusez-moi pour qu'elle
désigne un délégué à la protection de
Don je crois qu'il y a 58 % des communes
seulement entre guillemets qui ont
desésigné un déléger à la protection des
mais c'est compliqué naturellement pour
les plus petites même si elles peuvent
mutualiser ceci merci merci Madame nous
apprécions la qualité de vos réponses et
la précision de celle-ci qui va nous
engager dans quelques instants à
voter merci en tous les cas madame la
Présidente pour votre présence
et et donc les réponses que vous
apportez à nos questions il me reste à
vous demander de de quitter notre salle
de commission pour que nous
puissionsci voir ce que nous
décidonsident mesdames et messieurs
merci beaucoup
mercioup je je vous en prie jeis pas
in